nos dicen fausto vacía agua de la bañera
de su bebé
la gráfica siguiente muestra la relación
entre la cantidad de agua que queda en
litros y la cantidad de tiempo que ha
pasado en minutos desde que fausto
empezó a vaciar la bañera y nos hacen
algunas preguntas qué cantidad de agua
había cuando fausto empezó a vaciar la
bañera qué cantidad de agua se vacía
cada minuto y cada dos minutos cuánto
tardará la bañera en vaciarse por
completo pausa el vídeo y piensa si
puede resolver alguna o todas estas
preguntas con base en la gráfica que nos
dan
bien vamos a trabajar juntos vamos a
empezar con esta pregunta qué cantidad
de agua había cuando fausto empezó a
vaciar la bañera bien cuando nos
preguntan sobre la cantidad de agua en
la bañera cuando fausto empezó a vaciar
la bañera nos preguntan la cantidad de
agua ente igual a cero si te igual a
cero está aquí entonces podemos fijarnos
qué cantidad de agua había en la bañera
que es justo acá en este punto y es que
cuando observamos la gráfica a menudo
tiene una etiqueta especial que nos dice
que este es el eje james y este es el
eje x pero cuando miden el tiempo
algunos le llaman el eje m
pero por el bien de este vídeo
llamémosle eje x
entonces el punto donde se intersecta al
eje y la ordenada al origen nos dice
cuál es el valor de cuando x es igual a
cero o dicho de otra manera cuál es la
cantidad de agua en la bañera en el
tiempo te igual a cero así que la
ordenada al origen la ordenada al origen
nos dice cuál es la cantidad de agua con
la que iniciamos en la bañera y podemos
ver que eran 15 litros si estoy leyendo
la gráfica correctamente si son 15
litros ok
qué cantidad de agua se vacía cada
minuto y cada dos minutos
pausa el vídeo cuál crees que sea la
respuesta
muy bien lo que realmente nos preguntan
es la tasa cuál es la tasa a la que se
vacía el agua cada minuto
así que intentemos encontrar dos puntos
en esta gráfica este de aquí me parece
claro cuando t es igual a 1 hay 12
litros de agua en la bañera y luego
entre igualados hay 9 litros en la
bañera por lo tanto parece que en el
transcurso de un minuto más un minuto
que pasa con el agua en la bañera bueno
el agua en la bañera descendió de 12
litros a 9 litros es decir menos 3
litros y esta es una recta así que esto
seguirá pasando cuando pasa otro minuto
bajaremos otros 3 litros y es justo lo
que está pasando puedes verlo por lo
tanto podemos decir que la bañera se
vacía aún
de 3 litros por minuto se vacía a 3
litros por minuto y nos preguntan y cada
dos minutos bueno si vaciamos 3 litros
por cada minuto se va se hará el doble
cada 2 minutos entonces 6 litros por
cada 2 minutos 6 litros por cada 2
minutos fuimos capaces de obtener esta
segunda respuesta al obtener la
pendiente de esta recta por lo tanto en
este contexto la ordenada al origen nos
dice la cantidad con la que empezamos y
la pendiente nos dice la tasa a la que
cambia el agua en la bañera y por último
nos preguntan cuánto tardará la bañera
en vaciarse por completo pausa el vídeo
e intenta obtener la respuesta
bueno la situación donde la bañera se
vacía por completo es decir donde ya no
hay agua en la bañera es lo mismo que
pensar que nuestro valor o el valor de
la cantidad de agua disminuyó a cero
esto pasa cuando la gráfica está en este
punto este punto donde la gráfica inter
seca al eje x o lo podemos llamar
abscisa al origen lo podemos encontrar
en este contexto al preguntar hoy en
cuál es el valor de x cuando no tenemos
ningún valor en yen es decir cuando el
agua se ha vaciado y puedes ver que eso
pasa cuando x tiene el valor de 5 eso
nos da el tiempo en minutos por lo tanto
esto pasa en el tiempo
e igual a cinco minutos después de cinco
minutos toda el agua se ha vaciado y es
completamente cierto si tienes 15 litros
y se vacía a una tasa de 3 litros por
minuto entonces es lógico que en cinco
minutos se vacíen los 15 litros de la
bañera